[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour un nouveau numéro du 7-8 échos
votre magazine consacré à l'actualité
économique dans les yvelines tout de
suite le sommaire accompagner les
entreprises dans leurs projets
d'innovation
la spécialité de generix group ce
cluster basée à magny les hameaux a
lancé la construction de son nouveau
siège à guyancourt
avec comme perspective de poursuivre son
développement record pour le sky
business des 4000 rendez vous sur une
journée le bilan de cette troisième
édition au vélodrome nationale des
rencontres entre les entreprises du
territoire
objectif favoriser la dynamique du
business saint quentinois les détails
dans cette édition
enfin retrouvez l'actualité économique
en bref avec la visite de l'ambassadrice
du canada en france dans les yvelines et
l'acquisition d'une entreprise allemande
par le groupe lui en courtois socotec
elle s'inspire au quotidien de la
silicon valley avec ses méthodes et son
état d'esprit
l'entreprise generis groupe installé
actuellement à magny les hameaux a lancé
la construction de son futur siège
cette société spécialisée dans
l'accompagnement de ses clients dans
leurs innovations connaît une croissance
continue depuis 2011
en moyenne 30% par an les explications
dans ce reportage
c'est le futur siège juillan courtois de
gennari ce groupe cette entreprise saint
quentinois se transformer en cluster en
2011 accompagne les grands groupes dans
leurs projets d'innovation avec douze
entités en perpétuelle évolution 20
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
et 30 % de croissance par an la société
a besoin d'agrandir son espace il était
important qu'on puisse donc construire
qu'on puisse construire un bâtiment qui
conviennent à la fois à notre
développement et princesses et aussi
donc à la capacité de créer un
écosystème d'innovation pouvoir donc
pouvoir donc proposé à des start-up
pouvoir composer à des dans un cadre de
coordination autres donc les lois de
technologies nouvelles façons de
travailler donc voilà on sera plus à
l'aise chez nous spécialisé sur la
filière électronique et des objets
connectés gennari ce groupe propose des
solutions pour le secteur de
l'automobile avec un état d'esprit
collaboratif avec les grandes
entreprises les
aimé ou encore les startups reçu dans
cet espace la bubble farm
l'important c'est de connaître leurs
problématiques d'apprendre les découvrir
quels sont leurs besoins et répondant à
leurs besoins il se trouve que dans le
monde de la voiture et de l'électrique
de l'électronique et se trouvait de
l'ofce connectés de la voiture autonome
vous imaginez bien qu'à ce moment il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de beaux coups
beaucoup de besoins beaucoup d'intérêt
c'est d'exercer l'activité d'open
innovation alors c'est un grand mot mais
qui vise effectivement à mettre en
relation dans le but d'innover des
grandes structures telles que des grands
groupes et des acteurs qui sont de
taille plus réduite mais qui aussi leurs
caractéristiques d'agilité que sont les
start up et les pme lassé des réflexions
sur les la voirie du futur comment
arriver à rendre la voiture à la voirie
connectés interconnecté le sujet de
d'avenir creed engineering a rejoint le
cluster dès sa création en 2015 une
opportunité pour cette entité
travaillant sur la mobilité de demain
ça nous a permis de profiter des moyens
profiter des infrastructures du cluster
est aussi d'être dans un écosystème qui
a permis de nous développer de 2000 m²
le siège va passer à 4400 mètres carrés
déménagement prévu début 2011 20 des
grands groupes des pme et tpe
ajoutez y le vélodrome nationale et vous
obtenez le sky business day cette
troisième édition organisée par saint
quentin en yvelines le 8 novembre
dernier a attiré plus de 1000
participants aient permis 4000 mise en
relation retour sur cet événement le
montage est signée xavier jaglin la
troisième édition du sky business day au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
c'est plus de 1000 participants près de
700 entreprises présentes dont 70%
originaire de saint quentin en yvelines
des rencontres entre dirigeants de
grands groupes de pme et de tpe
le principe 25 minutes d'entretien pour
échanger sur les activités convaincre et
peut être décrocher des contrats
[Musique]
c'est le pionnier de cet événement le
président de saint quentin en yvelines
jean michel fourgous bonjour alors c'est
la troisième édition du sky business des
revenants déjà sur les deux premières
éditions quel bilan vous faites de ses
deux premières éditions et bien que
c'est un événement qui trouve toute sa
place dans une agglomération très
économique comme saint quentin en
yvelines
vous savez c'est un des groupes pib
comme on dit en france et 2e pib par
habitant donc bien sûr ici c'est une
plateforme d'hypercroissance un modèle
de plateforme d'hypercroissance saint
quentin donc voilà on est ici pour
inventer pour pour pour accélérer la
croissance de nos entreprises donc on
est là pour que les petits surtout des
entreprises qui ont du mage les pouvoirs
à rentrer en relation avec une grande
entreprise avoir le bon décideurs pour
vendre leurs produits vins est bien ici
on est un démultiplicateur de rencontres
entre les petites entreprises et les
grosses entreprises pour qu'ils
travaillent plus ensemble
en plus on avait plusieurs fois constaté
que des grosses entreprises travaillent
et des fournisseurs qui était à plus de
1000 km2
de 50 ans et il ne savait pas que il y
avait le même fournisseur
à
qui le met de l'entreprise vous dire que
henry z à découvrir aussi qu'
aujourd'hui avec près de 17000
entreprise de 50 alors je vous dirais
avant que les entreprises aillent
chercher ailleurs mais qui commencent à
regarder à près de chez eux
cet événement participe à la réussite du
tissu économique saint quentinois
d'abord vous augmenter la compétitivité
du site saint quentin en yvelines
c'est ce qui est évident que quand vous
avez des événements comme ça
bien sûr vous vous augmentez vous
faciliter la vie de leur simplifier donc
le choix de l'heure des talents qui vont
qui vont utiliser
donc en termes de petites entreprises
un dernier mot sur l'accompagnement que
saint-quentin prend en charge par
rapport aux tpe/pme comment vous faites
pour accompagner au quotidien les tpe et
pme du territoire en bus est plein de
choses mais c'est moi j'aurais adoré
quand j'écris ma
les start-up j'aurais des horaires un
environnement comme ça
pour être formés à déposer un statut
juridique faut pas vous plantez ensuite
déposé un brevet faut pas vous planter
mon épouse est vraiment les aides et
ensuite trouver du capital
il faut faciliter le capital vers
l'entreprise c'est ça qui crée la
richesse qui créent des emplois qui
créent de nouvelles recettes pour l'état
et c'est donc
donc voyez on essaye aussi d aider à
trouver du capital d'eads et les
business angels ou des banques
on a un fonds spécial pour aider les
petites entreprises devront donc voilà
on les aide un peu un peu partout a
aussi accéléré la lola leur fichier de
prospects clients ici et ciblez vous met
pas en relation avec n'importe quelle
boîte carrée avec votre produit par
livourne et d'en cesser ses cibles voilà
donc ici bas en plus vous avez des start
up vous avez des voiliers un petit peu
des idées il ya des échanges dîner ou
s'il échange de surtout de contacts
commerciaux bien sûr
[Musique]
en compagnie de jean charles carrière il
est responsable de tout quand ergonomie
une tpe installés à promo paul à
montigny le bretonneux
bonjour bonjour alors est-ce que vous
pouvez déjà nous décrire votre activité
donc nous nous sommes spécialisés dans
des aménagements de postes de travail
ergonomique sur mesure et les maintien
dans l'emploi des personnes en situation
de handicap à travers diverses
applications et claviers spécifique pour
favoriser un travail de bien-être au
travail pour ces personnes en situation
de handicap
c'est votre première participation au
sky business dinners et la deuxième
alors qu'elle
qu'est ce que vous avez déjà tiré de cet
événement l'an dernier pas mal
d'affaires l'année dernière on a dû
faire comme 30000 euros 2
de contrat et tout dégager de plusieurs
rendez vous ici est plus là cette année
on espère faire deux fois plus c'est
l'un des groupes du cac40 présence sur
cette troisième édition du scale
business des la société générale et nous
sommes avec le responsable commercial du
marché des professionnels de saint
quentin en yvelines
bonjour bonjour donc vous êtes olivier
boudeville eux
quel est votre rôle en fait sur pour la
société générale
alors aujourd'hui j'anime une équipe en
fait de conseiller de clientèle
professionnels qui sont là pour
accompagner en fait des clients
professionnels
les clients professionnels qu'ils sont
basses et les artisans les commerçants
les professions libérales les tpe
en fait les dirigeants de tpe est donc
en fait l'idée c'est bien effectivement
d'accompagner tous tous ces
professionnels pour attirer les
accompagne dans leurs investissements
diverses et variées et dans leur
fonctionnement au quotidien votre
patience était vraiment essentiel
aujourd'hui sur le sky business day
alors l'idée aujourd'hui de notre
présence sur cette manifestation c'est
effectivement de trouver aussi
d'éventuels partenaires à proposer à nos
clients puisque en fait aujourd'hui on
va un peu au-delà de nos missions
effectivement d'accompagnement sur les
investissements et sur l'accompagnement
au quotidien du besoin dans le cadre de
nos clients c'est aussi de les orienter
vers des d'autres professionnels c'est
une forme de mise en relation de
professionnels entre professionnels en
fait il a déjà enchaîné plusieurs
rendez-vous pour sa première
participation au sky business des
maillets le weld est avec nous bonjour
bonjour vous êtes responsable
développement de smart formation c'est
une tpe basée à montigny le bretonneux
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire un peu plus sur votre activité
absolument alors nous sommes un
organisme de formation nous formons
langues et en informatique
depuis bientôt 31 ans et voilà deux ans
qu'on se lance dans les produits
innovants et qui technologies et
formation alors c'est des produits que
recherchent notamment des grandes
entreprises c'est pour ça que vous êtes
présents aujourd'hui
absolument on a voulu faire deux choses
la première c'est rencontrer les grands
groupes parce que c'est un axe de
développement pour nous qui est très
intéressant et également créer des
partenariats arrêté avec d'autres
start-up de
de l'environnement saint quentinois en
quoi cet événement participe au au
développement à la force du tissu
économique de 50 ans déjà il faut
rencontrer les gens et grâce à ça moi
aujourd'hui ja ce matin j'ai rencontré
un paquet de personnes j'étais en train
de prendre un café tout à l'heure
quelqu'un nous a entendu discuter avec
une autre un autre collaborateur un
autre acteur de saint quentin
ça a fait tilt on s'est mis à discuter
ensemble les règles de rencontrer les
gens de savoir ce qu'ils font est
essentiel pour nous pourquoi aller
chercher à toulouse ce qu'on peut
trouver à 50 ans c'est pas uniquement
décrocher des contrats c'est aussi les
échanges entre personnes
absolument et je pense que faire partie
d'un écosystème c'est essentiel peu
importe peu développement qu'on soit via
le web
merci beaucoup merci à vous
[Musique]
prochain grand rendez-vous économique au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines c en piste
pour l'emploi prévue le 4 avril 2019
un rendez vous où les demandeurs
d'emploi pourront venir rencontrer des
recruteurs
passons tout de suite à l'actualité
économique en bref
l'ambassadrice du canada en france dans
les yvelines invité par les députés
marie le bec et aurore bergé elle a
visité plusieurs entreprises de
rambouillet des sociétés concernées par
les exportations vers le canada
des échanges facilités par le ceta
traité de libre-échange avec ce pays
nord américains dans les yvelines des
exportations atteignent 81 5 millions
d'euros le territoire canadien présent
aussi dans le département avec la
société nitel astra basé à guyancourt
la france fait avec le canada ce qu'elle
fait en moins d'une semaine avec
l'allemagne d'un point de vue d'
échanges commerciaux et en retour le
canada fait avec la france ce que nous
faisons en moins de trois jours avec les
états unis
donc il ya énormément de potentiel pour
exporter d'un côté et de l'autre de
l'atlantique notre savoir faire nos
biens nos services
restons à guyancourt installé dans cette
commune le groupe socotec vient
d'acquérir la société allemande schollen
burger entreprise spécialisée dans la
détection d'explosifs dans les
sous-sols-- milieu marin socotec double
son chiffre d'affaires réalisé en
allemagne de 40 millions à 80 millions
d'euros
signe de sa bonne santé économique pour
cette entreprise implantée
historiquement sur saint quentin en
yvelines une plateforme pour mettre en
relation les acteurs de l'innovation sur
paris saclay lancé le 8 novembre dernier
plus de 4 100 startups ont été recensées
ainsi que des lieux de développement
d'innovation
objectif faciliter les échanges les
installations et des rencontres avec des
investisseurs
c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de nous
avoir suivis et à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]